good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone's having a great thursday are
you having a great thursday so far i
mean it's thursday so it could be monday
it's true thursday is a beautiful day
it's friday eve it's lovely i have not a
nary a complaint if i had to complain i
guess i could complain about the fact
that it's raining theo is soaking wet
dirt everywhere chaos everywhere if i
had to i'll complain about is that this
is just amazing weekend weather and
i would prefer because it's like
sleeping weather so cozy chilly weather
it's so hard to get out of bed on a
weekday when it's raining it's so hard
and there's like overcast you're like oh
is it is it four in the morning is my
alarm not no [ __ ] you're late get up
that's your new alarm [ __ ] you're late
get up that'll do it especially coming
from you totally you're such a scary
voice do i sometimes perfect for
motherhood i feel like oh i'm gonna have
to work on my stern talking to you yes i
worked on it yesterday when i talked to
you guys about austin yeah but i feel
like my voice is so kid-like no like
even when you get heated oh and also
when i listen to old episodes even a
year ago our voices are constantly
changing what is that do other people
feel that way like of course five years
ago we sound totally like kids but even
a year ago no it's like our it's not
it's our tone it's our dialect it's our
accents like it's everything it's
everything we're just constantly
evolving changing as we should as we
should you do love to see it you love to
see
girlies growing up you love it speaking
of speaking uh i had such a productive
day yesterday and i recorded a very
exciting patreon episode i just want to
explain it to you guys because i've been
obviously breastfeeding for three months
and i've been working with a lactation
consultant named chantal who's our
friend from high school and she has been
instrumental in getting me to where i am
and i had done a breastfeeding episode
on patreon that was just about my
personal journey all my think learnings
whatnot but i brought chantal on for an
episode because she is the expert and we
took so many questions people ask like
such
in-depth personal pertinent timing
because a lot of people are freaking out
with the formula shortage to see if like
they have stopped breastfeeding for like
a month can i get back into it yes and
long story short you can get back into
it it can be done it is a lot of work
chantal said but also for a lot of
pregnant women right now who maybe like
weren't planning on breastfeeding or
didn't put much stock into the idea are
now like how am i going to make it work
what can i do to ensure that it will
work for me and so chantal just had like
so many great tips resources products
everything the episode is an hour and 17
minutes like
just
all about them titties and it's
really really great so if you are
curious in the least about any of it
head over head over to patreon.com the
morning toast i agree
and there's just so much premium content
over there anyway we have part two of a
general q a coming over our heads and
the general q and a's are just frisky
there's nothing better than jackson
claude general actually you know it's
better than jackson claude claude and
jack's
the only thing better than jackson
claude is jack's claude bryson thrice uh
hundred percent or actually you know
it's the only thing better than jack's
claude bryce and thrice
jack's claude bryce thrice k and harry
that's too much my cup runneth over
i'm wearing bryce on my chest today like
he's just a fashion he's in your heart
he's in my heart he's always in my heart
i love these pillows so much thank you
to everyone who gives us this merge that
just
warms the cockles of our hearts we have
an amazing show for you guys today
because it's thursday which means we're
just relaxed you know like we have this
sort of aura about us that some people
would say is uplifting spiritual and um
everything of the sort some people would
say that some people would not um we
also have the real housewives of beverly
hills we also have a little real
housewives of beverly hills recap second
episode of the season last night and i
have many thoughts i have a lot of
thoughts too i am like going to bed
earlier now my whole schedule has really
changed as a mama and because harry gets
his longest stretch of sleep after 8 p.m
so like i gotta get down for that so
i've been going to sleep around 10 i
didn't watch beverly hills last night
but i watched it this morning up until
the end of harry hanlon's birthday also
i didn't realize harry hamlin another
iconic harry totally now when lisa's
like harry's 70. i'm like he's three
months
but he's a good harry to be in the mix
with yes he's extremely you know dapper
successful he's a really great guy
harry hamlin yeah
it's real like i think what are you
gonna say i don't know what are you
gonna say like
no i won't no me neither but we're gonna
say the same thing i don't know what
you're gonna say
like he's like everything of the sort
for one tiny little thing
yeah
like they really do seem like a mismatch
to me i know but they're so in that and
they're really like couple goals that's
what i was gonna say a mismatch but like
yeah 30 years they're ride or die like
they have a beautiful family and they
really balance each other out it's not
what i would have expected no not at all
and like there's no drama there there's
never like rumors and he's so famous
like around people of that caliber
there's always like mistress like
there's they're just like real normal
people yeah they're very solid and he
lets brenna be rina and he doesn't like
you know she troll her no he doesn't
control her he also like doesn't tell
her what to do not that she can be told
and it's really a beautiful relationship
no i agree it's so weird because like
because it's chaos
and like she actually i think of all the
shows maybe like kyla murray too but
she's like one of the most stable home
lives yeah for one of the most chaotic
housewives it's crazy yeah get you a
queen who could do both agreed um so we
will be recapping the real housewives of
beverly hills and we're just gonna be
chatting about other things mostly
ourselves it's gonna be a great day here
at the morning toast yeah we have some
really great stories a nice mix and i'm
excited to get into it so without
further ado do you think that it's time
i do
no more ado for you
without further ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
nailed it today's episode is brought to
you by thuma your bedroom deserves a
refresh and now is the perfect time to
elevate the most important room in your
home with thuma well for two queens who
spend
90 percent of their days in their
bedrooms thuma has been an absolute
godsend they practice an intentional
less is more design philosophy for the
bedroom that means clean linens subtle
curves and life-enhancing details thuma
proves that simplicity is the truest
form of sophistication so the bed by
thuma is handcrafted from eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood and you'll
find beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain the minimalist design
featuring japanese joinery it helps
elevate any space and it's a super
supportive
bed for your mattress it's breathable
and it's made to naturally minimize
noise and create space
it's also made for how you live the bed
by thuma is backed with a lifetime
warranty it ships right to your door in
three easy to maneuver boxes and it
takes about five minutes to assemble and
no tools are required that is the most
important thing like if you've ever been
in the trenches with your partner trying
to set up something with like a thousand
little screws like you know how bad that
is for your mental health looking for a
phillip phillips screw right so fuma is
good for your mental health is what i'm
trying to say
they offer ton of other bedroom
essentials to elevate bedtime they have
the nightstand the side table the tray
and they're all perfect compliments to
the bed and they work with one tree
planted to plant one tree for every bed
and nightstand sold so create that
feeling of checking into your favorite
boutique hotel suite but at home with
the bed by thuma and now go to thuma dot
co slash toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental us go
to t h u m a dot c o slash toast that's
t h u m a dot c o slash toast for 25
credit great thank you claudia our
pleasure
story is a claudia special taylor swift
spoke at nyu commencement yesterday and
she told the grads to embrace cringe oh
my god that's so funny i didn't read the
whole um i didn't watch the whole speech
because honestly she was making me
cringe like and you know i'm i'm a
taylor stand till i die but like one of
the things that we love about her is
like she really is like a choogy cringy
queen and when i was watching the
the speech i was like oh my god cringe
that's so funny so here are some iconic
quotes from her speech where she
received an honorary doctorate of fine
arts on wednesday from nyu and also
delivered the commencement speech at
yankee stadium iconic she said i'm 90
sure the main reason i'm here is because
i have a song called 22.
now despite not receiving a four-year
college experience she used her almost
20 minutes speech to give the graduates
life hacks on navigating postgraduate
and early career life including quote
life can be heavy and to learn to live
alongside the cringe she said quote hard
things will happen to us we will recover
we will learn from it we will grow more
resilient because of it as long as we
are fortunate enough to be breathing we
will breathe in breathe through breathe
deep breathe out and i'm a doctor now so
i know how breathing works she was being
funny because like doctor you know um
she looked amazing she was so excited to
be there like all the footage i saw on
like the little clips on tick tock in
the pictures but you never saw someone
more excited to be a part of something
in your entire life like she was really
honored which was really cute um and of
course she ended with
so why don't we keep dancing like we're
22 which is like cute obviously um but
the other thing i wanted to say that is
cute while you think about it uh this
speech is reminding me just graduation
in general gary gianetti has a short
story in his new book i have to read it
you need to read and this really should
have been someone's graduation speech
like if i ran to college i would invite
him to graduation to speak and say just
do a reading of this little short story
because it's about like the realities of
post-grad life and how [ __ ] miserable
it is and embarrassing and everything
else but then the end obviously is like
some of the highlights right and it just
really sums up like expectation versus
reality when you graduate oh that's
funny that's cute maybe someone should
do a reading of it someone should do a
reading of it um but what i was going to
say was my favorite part of the speech
that i actually liked um
was like when she was talking about how
like
don't let other people like make you
feel embarrassed for like being
enthusiastic about something like it's
okay to be like excited and really like
juiced up about something even if other
people aren't and that's like so taylor
you know she's like so always like
geeking out over everything and
everyone's like calm down
you need to come down so i loved it
obviously like as an nyu grad this hurt
for sure it felt personal it felt like
an attack um some of us were forced to
sit through billy crystal while others
got to be in the presence of taylor
allison swift like i just don't think
it's right i don't think it's fair but
you know that's a great message to tell
people at college graduation life isn't
fair
totally and that's what i took away from
the entire experience yeah but for these
grads like they think life will always
be this good yeah well they're actually
setting them up for failure yeah you
know what's so interesting that i think
just random so i wanted to talk about
taylor swift speaking at nyu today so i
like search taylor swift news like every
single article from every single
publication is the same headline taylor
swift tells grads to embrace cringe
embrace cringe and break like did she
say nothing else is that really the most
interesting thing that she said and you
guys all really that was your main
takeaway no it's yellow journalism it's
at it again no it's literally so crazy
no because it was like so much more yeah
but like one person like harped on that
quote did anybody else even watch it or
just like copying it and changing the
language totally um she also did get
like a little choked up when they were
introducing her they were just like
listing off her accolades which of
course are many and she was getting like
a little teary-eyed i was getting a
little teary-eyed it was really a
beautiful moment and she looked super
cute yes she did of course like
everyone's like looking for clues she
did wear leopard shoes
that's an interesting choice right like
not an obvious choice so obviously
everyone was like this means something
and they were really similar to the
shoes she wore in the blank space music
video in that iconic scene when she's
like
she's sitting on the floor on the marble
floor like with eye makeup running down
her face and she's like screaming crying
perfect storm and she's wearing leopard
shoes so all signs do point to 1989
being next yeah but she has like a few
things she needs and it's new york
and welcome to new york it's new york
also this love from 1989 has already
been released because it's in the
trailer okay 1989 you guys and wait
there's more oh my god wildest dreams
has already been released because when i
was trending on tick tock she was like
uh please use my version so she just
released it so it's ready it's ready
yeah so i've i like i'm almost 100 sure
it's 1989 and like that for me like
i don't want to talk to like i will not
be okay
when we get 1989 vault songs because
1989 is really like her harry styles era
like style obviously a lot of the songs
are about harry so like it's just going
to be unwell a lot of the songs are
about harry oh another great harry
another great harry potter made that
association because also his album's
called harry's house oh right so i need
to get merch you need a good luck for
harold well harold is on the uh today
show today and i've somehow ended up on
like the harry
fan tick tock and like get me out like i
like they're they're not okay probably
because your phone hears you being like
i love harry where's harry i want to see
harry or maybe like my phone picked up
on the fact that harry styles follows me
on instagram so they thought i would
want to see that content on tick tock
yeah yeah definitely that's what it was
and so he's performing at the today show
today and like his big um
he's doing like a one night only in new
york do you know that at an arena i
think in long island um and it's tonight
and like literally people have been
camped out like putting up tents it's
like insane that's pretty cool yeah i
think it's gonna be televised
pretty cool it's pretty cool yeah you
need to get your hands on harry's house
merch i do a perfect segue to our next
story about
music pretty cool events with a british
twist because queen elizabeth
star-studded platinum jubilee gig lineup
has been revealed
i love a jubilee queen elizabeth ii is
set to mark her 70 years on the throne
with a huge concert where the biggest
stars from around the globe are set to
perform the mega gig which will be
called platinum party at the palace oh
my god what i would give i love an
alliteration to be there will take place
at buckingham palace you need a live
podcast
you know the queen is a toaster right 1
million
do you know that she like has her tea
crumpets no of course and she's like
every morning those little jewish girls
they're so delightfully funny don't you
think so william and she loved our
halloween episodes loved and she loved
snitch's portrayal of her it was an
extremely flattering portrayal she said
helen mirren snitch i don't know the
biopic is getting you know more
competitive as the days go by olivia
coleman claire foyce no schmidt sorry no
olivia coleman she's top she is queen
snitch no it really it makes you think i
like how margo's um miss jarvis costume
and queen elizabeth costume were like
super similar i mean there are two icons
two queens yeah
okay here's who's performing at the
platinum party at the palace maybe ben
can get us invited because
if ben we've been talking about this a
lot lately ben can do anything no ben is
like one of those effervescent
charismatic charming he's one of those
people that you hear about um leading a
cult and you're like how did we get here
when you hear the accounts of people
being like you don't understand like the
magnetism of this guy like you just
wanted to be around him and and he was
so electric and his
his
laughter was contagious
that's been that's been like he uses his
powers for good and like he's really
just a really great networker and he has
a really big like circle of friends and
he just like uses it to get invited to
like the platinum party at the palace
yeah ben is always getting invited to
cool things and he's not doing like
anything nefarious with it but like a
different man would use those charms to
start a cult and be on an episode of
american greed yeah but he has that
personality where it's like wait how did
this person get into all those places no
totally i am going to put him on the
jubilee party now yes like if anybody
can do it ben can so here's who's
performing so far alicia keys wow han
zimmer
rod stewart duran duran elton john also
adam lambert will be performing with the
remaining members of queen
i love how adam lambert has become kind
of how like john mayer has become like
the fill-in for grateful dead yeah adam
lambert has become the fill-in for queen
and i just think that's
perfect no it's perfect like what a
great career not something that you
would like see for him but to be like
freddie mercury standin he's
extraordinarily talented he just like
never really took off in a mainstream
kind of way i think probably the height
of his career was his role on glee
honestly
interesting i forgot he was on glee so
i'm gonna have to say not
what do you think is the highlight of
his career american idol like this being
like yes being the stand-in for freddie
mercury and also what's cool is that the
queen's uh jubilee her golden jubilee
which was 20 years ago queen played at
and now they're playing again also with
a name like queen like they have to be
invited of course i think that's
literally why they named their man queen
but there are a lot of iconic british
artists who i would have expected to see
this sounds very american like what
about adele uh elton john obviously that
comes to mind is obvi obvious yes harry
styles right would be good even though
like i imagine the jubilee has to be
like somewhat of like an elevated soiree
and like harry is very much like a
rocker
so someone like elton john makes sense
someone like
like a little mix wouldn't make any
sense you know what i mean they little
mix always makes sense but it's because
they're on break i think that it just
doesn't work out yeah i don't know it
just seems um
seems very american but yeah also it's
giving like festival vibes because there
are there are more performances from
other smaller british musicians so it's
like multi-stage you know it's going to
be like projected on the palace walls i
think so there are smaller musicians
like ella iyer who i love craig david
mabel elbow george ezra mimi webb mimi
webb is one of my favorite artists these
days i can't even tell you not in
familiar yes you are the house on fire
song that
but
snitch
is
also like listened to her album called
it's the vibe and don't come to it in
five years with downtown yellowstone
also sam ryder jack jones you know who
needs to be invited to this sam smith
snitch these are her people yeah no but
like honestly the lineup feels a little
weird like we're like the major major
british
adele i know adele is the glaring
obvious obviously person but between
elton john queen rod stewart
i mean
like we do want the queen to enjoy it
and she
is 90 years old so like she probably is
a big rod stewart girlie also the
evening will feature appearances by
david attenborough david beckham david
attenborough david attenborough is like
the queen's girly he's like the british
morgan freeman
is he an actor i don't know but he's
known for his voice
because he's a host he's a not a host
he's like a narrator yeah he's a
narrator it's his voice on every episode
of planet earth any like nature
documentary where you hear like this
wise old man like
in the lee of a picturesque ridge
lies a small
unpretentious
unpretentious one right
um love david attenborough of course the
beckham's are going to be there yeah so
hopefully nicola will be there too
stephen fry and julie andrews and there
will be a special performance from the
royal ballet so they are bringing out
all the stops as they should because
it's the queen's 70th which is
unprecedented it's like that um scene in
greatest showman when they're all those
entertainers are like going to the
queen's house
literally they saw queen victoria and
dash and jenny lynn
who is adele is not there literally also
oh in the show victoria is that what
you're talking about no in the greatest
showman in the greatest show yes they go
and perform for queen victoria but also
in the show victoria you know they talk
about jenny lind
no i haven't gotten there yet that's
really fun crossover oh wait jenny lynn
was a real person yeah
shuck
you know the hill like i will die on is
that that girl was miscast as jenny lynn
i don't i think the movie's perfect i
wouldn't change a thing no i wouldn't
change your hair on its head you know
what i would change the fact that the
girl whose voice is actually jenny lynn
is like out here on america's got talent
that's disgraceful yeah but she's making
the royalties and she gets to live a
normal life and go to the supermarket
no she's she doesn't want a normal life
because she's on america's got talent
she wants i'm always seeing videos of
her on tick tock and it's like yeah i'm
the girl like
no but i think she was doing all those
videos are from before greatest showman
i don't know because no she's saying
yeah i'm the girl from greater showman
yeah okay
i just don't think it's right like the
way she was shafted lauren allred yeah
and i don't want to ruin the platinum
jubilee but i did just see something
that's
giving red flags what the queen's love
for musicals will also be commemorated
as special appearances from james corden
weber james corden will be there mark my
words he will be there but lin-manuel
miranda is going to be there as well as
well as stars from the cast of the
phantom of the opera hamilton sixx the
lion king and joseph and the amazing
technicolor dreamcoat james corden will
be there mark my words one thousand
percent row center camcorder he's
literally british yeah and he is in
musical theater and i think
knowing him and i think that james
corden has the ben factor because it's
like why else is this man literally
going to be sitting next to the queen
like i think people just love him that's
actually a really really good call the
ben factor the ben factor could explain
a lot yeah no that's true and i
definitely as like consumers of pop
culture we don't understand like the
personal ins and outs of like
relationships in hollywood so james
corden is definitely like that guy for
sure he's probably super nice yeah funny
engaging likes to connect people you
know he went on vacation with adele and
harry styles like he brings people
together
um he will definitely be there and it's
sad that lin manuel has to ruin a
perfectly lovely affair it's
it's really it's not right it's
disrespectful to the queen and actually
to the monarchy a perfectly lovely
evening at buckingham palace i hope that
it's live stream somewhere so uh us lay
people can watch um but also the queen
has been really low-key yeah and she's
been skipping out on some tings because
wouldn't you after 70 years 100 like you
can't get me out of bed right for less
than duran duran and john and queen yeah
you know but
she's obviously always going to the
opening of an envelope and so i think
people are like worried about queenie i
know but people are always worried about
queenie and i'm not worried about
queenie until there's something to be
worried about yeah no i just i'm always
thinking of her skipping events when
literally your day is back to back to
back and you're literally 95 years old
like can she take a nap no no they're
always wanting more from her that
doesn't work
for me more and when i see her she looks
lively like towards the end when we saw
philip it was like that looks like a
person who's
struggling
she looks fresh fresh to death but we
haven't seen her in a while refreshed to
death
we haven't seen her in a while yeah but
i'm telling you next time i see her
she's gonna be lit i hope she's just
been taking some time for herself
relaxing rejuvenating getting a massage
new season of queen
yeah yeah are you ready for our next
story only if it's a story that's
brought to you by noom it is every story
is brought to us by you my whole life is
brought to you by noom right now you
guys all right you guys sign up for your
trial at noon and get the
psychology-based support and motivation
to reach your goals if you go to
noom.com toast that's n o o m dot com
slash toast you can sign up for your for
the trial noom weight makes it easy to
start on your weight loss journey and
stay on track their personalized lessons
help you gain confidence with practical
knowledge you can employ right away with
one-on-one coaching you'll always have
guidance and support on your journey
nume wait's cognitive behavioral
approach teaches you how to be more
mindful of your habits and it gives you
the knowledge you need to continue
building long-term positive habits
i know that you've had a lot of
experience with neuma specialty
postpartum can you tell me a little bit
about that yes so i've been using new
for years what i love about noom is like
when your goals change your
priorities change new changes with you
right now i'm in a completely different
space than i once was and noom is like
my friend my crutch that is there for me
helping me guiding me through i feel
like right now my biggest struggle which
is not something that i've had in the
past is like uh not knowing where i'm
going wrong on certain days and like
noom is like oh no here because i'm
tracking everything that i'm doing and
also right now i'm like hungrier than
i've ever been and nume is like
recommending and their calorie counter
shows me like how i can get the best
meals the best snacks packed full of
nutrients that are going to keep me full
and also help me achieve my goals so i
love nume they have an amazing database
of so many foods that when you put it
all together shows you what you're
eating in a day new weight uses a
psychology-based approach that adapts to
your lifestyle it's flexible approach
focuses on progress not perfection and
allows you to work towards your goal at
a pace that's comfortable for you so
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com toast that's
n-o-o-m-dot-com
toast
great okay our next story so jennifer
lopez has a documentary coming out yes
called halftime and she is breaking down
over her oscars snub she said it gave me
low self-esteem jennifer lopez put on a
brave face after failing to nab a
nomination for best supporting actress
at the 2020 oscars the superstar was
secretly devastated by the snub after
wowing critics with her role as a
scheming stripper in hustlers the full
extent of her sorrow is revealed for the
first time in the netflix documentary
halftime which will be released next
month in a trailer for the doc that
dropped on wednesday the actress is seen
sobbing in bed after being overlooked
for the honor by the academy of mosher
picture arts and sciences she said it
was hard i just had very low self-esteem
i had to really figure out who i was and
believe in that and not believe in
anything else she has long struggled
with self-doubt about her career telling
the post in 2018 everybody was like she
can't sing she can't dance she can't act
she's just a pretty face or her butt is
big or whatever they were saying about
me i started thinking yeah that's true
and it really hurt me for a long time
despite the hurt and the pain i just
kept going i just couldn't allow myself
to let that become who i was okay first
of all when the trailer dropped like i
gasped because i was just not expecting
this
the last halftime super bowl netflix
show i saw was lady gaga five foot two
which is on my list of top 10 best
celebrity documentaries of all time so
i'd love to see a super bowl show from
start to finish because it's so much
work but then also seeing a more
personal i feel like i don't really know
jennifer lopez on a deep level and you
know what the fact that she knows like
all the things people say about her and
what gets her down is so sad and like
you know what i thought she was great in
hustlers and a lot of people forget like
she was an actress first selena um
and like she says like my whole career
have like been struggled i've struggled
with being taken seriously and it's so
true like yeah she doesn't have any
grammys like it's so weird it is weird
and i
kind of just assume that like she holds
this like interesting place in pop
culture where she is a-list beyond but
on a serious like critical level she
doesn't get that recognition and i just
would have assumed that she like is so
okay with all of that like she's the one
laughing all the way to the bank like
kind of like jessica simpson where it's
like
i'm never gonna be or you guys don't
respect me right now but that doesn't
bother me because i have the things that
matter and i have so much success i have
so many fans i have a beautiful life and
a beautiful family and i have a ton of
money and like you guys can go [ __ ]
yourself
and to hear that like this actually
affects her is surprising and it reminds
me of when taylor swift and miss
americana was like so upset that
reputation didn't get shine at the
grammys and like you just think that
these artists are above it and the way
that even i look at award shows i think
a lot of people do and more so now it's
irrelevant irrelevant and it's so much
about politics about like campaigning
about you know wheeling and dealing and
gifts and bribery and who's friends with
who and who knows who that it's like
not the real it's not real like if you
won best actress it doesn't necessarily
mean you were the best actor it's not a
nobel peace prize like right it just
means like you know everything came
together at the right time
it's not fan voted it's so
i'm always surprised when major artists
with so much success who this doesn't
make or break your career get so bogged
down by these no you're right it's weird
but like at the end of the day like they
everyone grows up with a dream yeah yeah
and so if your dream is to win a grammy
or an oscar and like you're so close to
it and you don't get to it like the hurt
is understandable yeah no that hurt and
at the end of the day she's literally
jenny from the block you know she's just
a girl with a dream and i guess when
you're in this world everything seems so
big and to go from being an actress to
an oscar-nominated actress is a big jump
especially for someone like jennifer
lopez who like doesn't acting career is
always like struggling to be taken
seriously wait she didn't get any
nominations for selena
i guess that's a that's that's a bigger
shock than hustlers jennifer lopez
[Music]
of you tonight till tomorrow
i'll be holding you down
and there's nowhere in the world i'd
rather be
than here in my room
[Music]
dreaming about you and me
gorgeous song thank you re grammy she's
been nominated twice
for waiting for tonight and let's get
loud but she did not win two of
seriously the most i name two songs that
have aged better i couldn't i really
couldn't oh man i'm trying not to sing
too much but like whoa
and you know what let's get loud like
when that [ __ ] was popping out about
mitzvot like i
i would lose my [ __ ] mind no let's
get loud no and i think that's us and
get like do you know what we should do
get loud
hundred percent yeah and in the category
of oscars it's not even there
disgraceful disgraceful she should have
been nominated for selena and she was
really good in hustlers i don't know
what else was nominated that year but
that was a good movie and it was you
know based on a true story and they love
that [ __ ] and she like when you see the
work she put in to learning like she did
all of her own stunts
like that's
worthy yeah and her halftime show should
have been nominated a hundred percent i
cannot wait to watch this documentary i
love celebrity documentaries especially
about the super bowl and i really do
love j lo and ben affleck is in it which
is so crazy
wow
see she like she she has it all like she
has a family i just wish i could tell
her like nobody cares about these things
like you have what matters yeah and you
know what you are more famous and more
relevant than you've ever been and
you've been in this business what is she
50 now since you were 20 yeah maybe
younger so it's like to have the height
of your career 30 years later be in the
best shape like
of course you never know what's going on
in someone's life and like whatever but
like from the outside it's like this
[ __ ] doesn't matter agreed and i'm sure
maybe 99 of the time that's how she
feels like i'm good this is good but
maybe in just that one moment where it's
like oh [ __ ] i didn't get that one thing
like you're allowed to have a low moment
no for sure and like okay so she was
doing hustlers filming training
casting like it was probably you know a
two-year process and obviously the whole
time her goal was most likely the oscar
so it's like to put so much time and
effort physical effort also into this
project and then two years later after
it all pays off not getting the thing
that i'm sure you really set into this
project with the intention of getting i
understand being disappointed yeah i
understand being disappointed for you
know however long it is and then right
okay remembering who you are right we're
supposed to like respect the oscars but
literally leonardo dicaprio didn't have
one arguably the greatest um actor of
our generation didn't have one up until
two years ago or three years ago before
yeah like make it make sense you
couldn't you couldn't if you tried no
and like little mix doesn't have a
grammy so disgraceful what did the
grammys even mean no and what did they
mean yeah
the jonas brothers disgusting disgusting
when you actually look up like the
major major pop stars who don't have
grammys it's really interesting demi
lovato jonas brothers selena gomez miley
cyrus miley actually might have gotten
one recently since she went more niche
there's a wrong there yet
how do i look that up major artists who
don't have grammys right some of them
have like i believe selena has like two
nominations but i think when you go more
niche i know selena i think is gonna do
more latin music miley went more rock i
think it's easier to get those smaller
categories okay popular artists who have
surprisingly never won a grammy
katy perry
wow nicki minaj
no that's shocking blake shelton
it's like not shocking busta runs
two pack both have one
two sorry both have one nomination but
zero wins right now we're talking about
wins yeah we're talking about wins brian
mcknight no wins
one snoopy like a dream come true
two
just one that song was not nominated for
grammy and three
girl it's playing he's been nominated
seventeen times since 1993 and brian
mcdonald to win yeah all right we have
to start a campaign that you're the only
one for me and four repeat steps one
through three that song is
so good snoop dogg has been nominated 16
times and he has never won wow
bjork has been nominated 15 times never
won if bjork like came up to me in the
street and spit in my mouth i'd be like
what's your name i literally don't know
her
martina mcbride snubs
14 nominations never wow
dirk spently 14 nominations never won
see with country there are so many men
who literally do the same thing so like
dirks and blake shelton they're just
like another luke bryan jason that just
like fell through the cracks right so
it's not surprising katy perry nominated
13 times never won that's insane diana
ross has won a lifetime achievement
award but never won see and like we're
supposed to respect these institutions
jayla look at this link yeah you're in
great company yeah brian mcknight
sia has nine nominations but hasn't win
this gabby it's disgusting and this is
from april 2022. that's
right she writes songs for other people
including ed sheeran beyonce like please
queen has had four nominations but no
wins have you heard of bohemian rhapsody
have you heard it that's insane have you
heard it grammys
happy morning grammys
um that's so interesting
the beach boys
zero grammys
sammy davis jr has a lifetime
achievement award but no grammy this
should be like embarrassed to be giving
out lifetime achievement awards to
people it's like well you didn't think
his his lifetime was worth achieving
back in the day when he was nominated
dean martin has a lifetime achievement
award but no grammy
monogrammy
has one grammy nomination but no grammy
okay like we're down in the list of
people i don't care about it yeah no now
we're getting like oh no not morrissey
uh anyways send the link to jlo everyone
yeah she'll be okay i'm so excited for
this documentary and netflix just puts
together like a premium ass documentary
except for very hot take sean mendez's
it was like really bad i couldn't even
finish it i didn't watch it i haven't
watched a documentary in a long time
because it it became really
oversaturated where like at first it was
like this great way of telling your art
i mean i think some of the greatest of
all time are of course
joan rivers piece of work
katy perry part of me when she was going
through her divorce gaga five foot two
um but then it was like everyone was
doing it and it was like you're all not
that interesting some of you are but
some of you are not agreeing like and
she's my queen
i did watch mary j blige's and like she
actually you know what i take back hers
was good hers was good it was like a
like a little lengthy but what she
achieved
mary j's was good but like not the best
one i've ever seen but like not everyone
needs a documentary is what i'm saying i
agree yeah
okay why are you looking at me like that
because you just like keep being done
talking i'm like working through my
thought process you know i'm an artist
jackie my god i'm a creative stop trying
to stifle me i'm sorry that's me the
stifler literally i'm the sweeper and
you're the stifler
are you ready for our next story little
tv news
it's big changes at the cw because
riverdale is coming to an end after
seven years it is time and dynasty is
coming to an end after
five years so after revealing on
thursday that season seven would be the
final installment of riverdale the cw's
chairman and ceo expressed confidence
that the series was going out on a high
note the network announced the
conclusion of the show along with the
rest of its 2022 fall release schedule
so
what we are interested in is the end of
riverdale and the end of dynasty for me
the end of dynasty is sadder just
because i've been still watching it and
i love it and it's like a soap opera in
the sense that it doesn't really need to
end obviously the plot lines are insane
yeah but like it's a type of show that
could go on forever because you just
expect it's literally like days of our
lives yeah it's a telenovela it really
is and i always watch at the end of the
season and like i just really enjoy it
riverdale i stopped watching really
because it was too scary like it's so
scary so spooky and it was always just
like giving me the willies it's like it
is time
riverdale like lost the plot with the
green goblin monster
you gave up but like
yes it got but i will stand by the fact
that season one of riverdale is probably
some of the greatest television in the
last 10 years it got to a really scary
place but then like by the end of that
season they wrapped it up really nicely
and there was a good explanation for all
the spookiness not just like mystery and
magic
and they got back on track they really
did i just like couldn't keep watching
such a scary show i don't watch scary
tings i don't watch scary movies i don't
watch thrillers like i don't listen to
like murder mystery i don't watch true
crime and riverdale was going down that
path and that's just not my genre i'm
interested to see like what the cast
does because like they shot two insane
levels of stardom when the show
especially the first season like was so
buzzy but it's like and they're still
super famous like they go to that gala
but it's definitely like tapered off
quite a bit um and i'm sure they're all
excited not to be like in vancouver 11
months out of the year and like have
normal celebrity lives in like hollywood
um but i'm curious to see what they all
do next you know it's it's interesting
to see like how they've all been
positioning themselves like madeleine
patch has been really smart like she's
invested heavy in like youtube very like
shea mitchell and pretty little liars um
lily reinhardt is like very much like
she's like oh my god she's literally
like the troy and belisario like very
much in the activist space especially as
it pertains to body image which is
literally what troy belsario did um
camila mendes i don't know what her vibe
but she's like a fashion girly yeah
she's a fashion girly she's always
popping up in some netflix movies she's
always doing a great job yeah yeah yeah
yeah those are my favorite kind of
netflix movies like the better ones
is a supporting actress yeah i would
love to see her star i guess her
schedule well she did star in that one
with the house
spooky spooky movie it was a little
spooky does anyone remember no hold on
let me go to her imdb it was like you
know that the movie that was all talked
about for one weekend that's how that's
like every day yes
nothing is talked about so hard three
days and if you didn't that's why
queen's gambit was so monumental because
it literally was like a month yeah
because like it was a slow burn um
same with like bridgerton
dangerous lies was the movie got it um
yeah no you're totally right about like
literally everything having a shelf life
of 45 minutes yeah and it's getting
shorter and shorter like selling sunset
it's getting like it's getting shorter
and shorter and that's why it's like you
really don't have to watch everything
anymore just because it's a few days
hibernate everyone's talking about
exactly
literally exactly love is blind like
that other one ultimatum you just i
truckered through that yeah it's over
nobody cares anymore the coast is clear
it's so [ __ ] true it's crazy but all
of those people really get so many like
followers in that time and then you know
it's what you do with it thereafter yeah
yeah just interesting factoid no
littering facts left right and center
and for dynasty everyone should watch
the five seasons that are available
because you know
they're beautiful i wouldn't be
surprised if dynasty got picked up by
netflix because it's huge on netflix and
it's really big globally i don't think
anybody tunes in on cw weekly i haven't
recorded but when that [ __ ] hits netflix
especially internationally
all the cast is like crazy millions of
fans like i think netflix would actually
be smart to pick it up yeah and just
keep doing the same [ __ ] yeah tell a
novella netflix doesn't have any like
soap operas that's a good idea
thanks for the idea
are you ready for a fifth and final
story don't i look ready you actually
look so ready you've never been more
ready for anything it's the final story
[Music]
can't wait to see ben on an episode of
american
greed
and that's a magic
number why did you stop singing i forgot
my role like i forgot my place jesus i
thought get it together i do the doo doo
doo doos harry gets like one rash on his
face and you've lost the plot i'm sorry
i have so much going on there's so much
on your mind i understand no but i
literally forgot what my point is i
thought you were like finally you know
what let me just give it up let the girl
sing she has the better voice of the two
of us i forgot my purpose i forgot who i
was i forgot where i was
you know i do it does and juliana i
drink a lot of water
i just feel like sometimes people listen
to the show and have no idea what's
going on let me tell you let me explain
that one so
i never know sorry really quick okay i
never know whether to like do this show
in a manner where like i speak to people
who might be tuning in for the people
who might be tuning in for the first
time because we're over here like rise
and stress and rise and stress and like
is that turning people away from being
like what the [ __ ] is going on i think
perhaps but i also sometimes i follow
people and they have like inside jokes
on their instagram or whatever i'm like
okay i don't get this yet but eventually
i will and eventually they do explain it
so i do think every once in a while we
should just like pop up and explain so
bryson's jason those are our dogs so
real names theodore ashrae stopper bruno
sweets wine rub and we have many names
over the years right now bruno is bryce
and theo is trice he's also thrice so
brass and stress resin straws and brass
and stress and brass and straps and
brass and straps and brass and straps
and braxton shots and brass and
stretching so that's bryson streis also
known as bryson streisand oh yeah and he
strikes he strikes he strikes him yeah
so that's that that's that but what i'm
really saying so i forgot who i was i
forgot where i was is a quote from
claudia's special disgrace queen you can
get it on amazon anytime that you're
feeling for free for free oh my god
you're giving that [ __ ] away for free oh
[ __ ] has been free for years oh i
didn't know that yeah interesting and
then because i was quoting her special i
went to a go-to quote of mine which is
juliana i drink a lot of water also if
you hear jackie say claudia
that's beautiful also a quote from my
iconic comedy special i gotta go back
and watch that also these days i'm
loving so i'll always say to harry i'm
like harry your brother has paws big
paws hairy paws curly paws
also a quote from the special i wasn't
talking about paws i was talking about
pubes but you know what i mean big paws
hairy paws curly paws curly curly ones
[Laughter]
such a good comedy special uh there are
some other ones that i quote from that
yeah and you by the way like remember
more quotes from that special than i do
like once i started this new tour i had
to literally erase disgrace queen from
my brain or else i would have gotten
confused yeah no and once i get the new
tour on dvd on demand it's all i'm gonna
be saying also there are some
quotes from this your new show that i
would love to use on the show but i
don't want to there's some of them are
punch lines yes and i don't want to
spoil the punch line thank you like i'm
going to do a mannerism let me know if
you know what i'm thinking
yes
um
yeah yeah yeah and then also
mask yeah
that's a joke which one
yeah yeah yeah so i just like because i
know she's going to do more shows and i
don't want to ruin it but what i can say
when teacher smiles teacher is happy
yeah don't spoil that either when
teacher frowns teacher is sad that's all
i'll say so it's also some of my best
work well i'm hilarious and that's all
that needs to be said
so now are you ready for our fifth and
final story oh yeah we haven't even
gotten there yet no and it's some food
news that's exciting because mcflurry is
adding another flavor to its rotation
you know it's time it's time because we
have oreo which is the best and the
brightest and there's no need for
another agree but then they added eminem
which then opens up the floodgates no
and you know what like when i go to an
ice cream place like i am gonna get
eminem so i'm really an eminem girly but
i've never had an m mcflurry just
because like why would you get anything
other than the oreo here's the thing
about an m mcflurry m ms and ice cream
just don't work in general because they
get too hard and they crack your teeth i
think some people like that about it i
don't and like the oreo just enmeshes
itself in the ice cream the oreos they
become one it's literally perfect it's a
symbiotic germ well before you tell me
the flavor i do think mcdonald's should
invest more time in having working ice
cream machines then introducing a third
flavor that none of us are going to be
able to try because the ice cream
machines are never working okay no i'm
not like what came first the chicken or
the egg i agree that's another problem
but i am always here for the
introduction of new flavors new concepts
and now we have a new mcflurry which is
the chocolatey pretzel mcflurry a little
sweet and salty combo i am interested
no
for me look at this gorgeous girl let me
see
that's i mean it looks good but can i
say something like this is like an
extremely hot take and perhaps the
fattest thing i've ever said
if you don't like sweet and salty just
don't guess let me say it okay
pretzels are like too healthy
like they're not like a good snack like
pretzels just give health in my opinion
i'm sure like on the label they're not
healthy but like they are they're like
the healthiest of like junk food yeah
and like i just i want no part of it
like i think they're extremely toxic i
understand the association like
definitely you would have like pretty
like you have a carrot you would have a
pretzel yeah like i mean kendall jenner
was eating pretzels on the last episode
how about should they be right i hear
you i love a pretzel yeah no it's like
if i'm
having a bag of pretzels it's not like
i'm being crazy right and there's
nothing better than pretzels in a diet
coke
that i do and don't get me wrong there
are some moments when like i need a
pretzel and just to be extremely clear
i'm not talking about hot pretzels soft
pretzels that's a big snack that is the
best snack on the planet and you know
for someone who lives in new york i
don't think i've had one in like 15
years i had one remember when i was
pregnant and we were in a new we pulled
them on the side pulled up on the side
and grabbed one but there's literally
one on my corner no there's i should get
one today you should but here's the
thing and i actually i love a hot
pretzel it's one of my favorite quality
control it's one yeah it's one of my
favorite things so i do treat myself
like when i see it if i'm having a
touristy moment
um they're like not great anymore no you
have to find a good card if you go to
like central park i do believe they're
better but like some of the random ones
on the street they have bad quality
control no like hot i'm always on like
fifth avenue that's where i got yeah the
one that i'm thinking that like was i
haven't had a good one no the one where
you were thinking was like some turn to
get straight that one was turning i i i
don't fault it for not being good but
i'm thinking like right before i went to
pritikin and i got a hot pretzel and um
it wasn't that great no we need
we have a new mayor you know what i'm
we're gonna lobby this issue there needs
to be better quality control over the
pretzels because honestly they're an
iconic part of new york and if people
start coming to new york and having bad
experiences with pretzels it will affect
tourism which affects the overall gdp
and i think it's important that we have
this discussion yeah and everybody
benefits when the prices are better
you're making them anyway my white as
well make them better no and you know
what if they're if they're tasting
really delicious charge me more
hmm yeah you pay a premium i'll be a
premium for a delicious pretzel not one
that literally fell off the card like
literally literally literally anyways
pretzel mcflurry chocolate pretzel
mcflurry mcflurry and i think it sounds
delicious it will hit menus on may 25th
for a limited time so i think this is
something that's like if this is the
change that we want to see we're going
to have to show up no we're gonna have
to move on we'll have to mobilize we
have to put our money where our mouth is
and we need to be buying this if we want
them to do new flavor initiatives we
just do no we do and i want to support
but like i just can't imagine it's four
in the morning and i grab my phone and
instead of ordering an oreo mcflurry i
order a pretzel mcflurry like that's
just never going to happen it's not a
flooring you don't try new things at
four in the morning it's almost no but i
mean anytime i go to mcdonald's like i'm
never going to choose anything other
than the oreo mcflurry it's literally
the perfect recipe and that's kind of
like the achilles heel of mcdonald's
like they really can never introduce
more flavors because no matter how good
it is and i'm sure it's delicious nobody
is ever going to choose that over an
oreo unless you're allergic to oreos but
if you're allergic to oreos you're
probably allergic to ice cream too
yeah that's a good point what flavor
could they introduce
you know what sounds good like a peanut
butter reese's yes but the thing is at
least for me like when i go into an ice
cream shop i know i just said like i
will get m ms and i and i would but
that's only if they don't have cookies
and cream first like i am one thing
about me is like cookies and cream is my
flavor of choice whether i'm in the
grocery store whether i'm at an ice
cream parlor so i'm never not gonna
choose like if i could choose and if i
could have mcdonald's make me any flavor
it would be cookies and cream yeah
cookies and cream is my go-to also the
only time i don't get it is if they
don't have it like at 40 carats they
don't do cookies and cream so i get
vanilla with like reese's peanut butter
and i love a heath bar but you know what
i will say last month i did a patreon
vlog of my trip in vegas well i just
want a caveat i don't eat the heath bar
on the ice cream because again too hard
yes i just like to get it on the side so
i can eat a heat bar so i ordered
mcdonald's in the middle of the night
and
i got a mcflurry and when uh the uber
driver pulled up he was like they didn't
have the ice cream machine was broken
obviously he was like but i got you a
pie and i was like okay sure like i was
desperate
and i had this raspberry pie that was so
i vlogged it it is the funniest thing
patreon.com oh yeah it was the best
[ __ ] pie i've ever had in my
life like i need to have a sober one it
was so good maybe it was strawberry
something berry so good and i had never
had a pie for mcdonald's before do you
think it was so good because like you
were drunk no it's definitely sprayed
it's definitely possible but you know me
i'm not like
you're not someone who says something's
good when it's not right even drunk you
can't even trick yourself into thinking
something so i think it was really good
and it was like hot it was like a good
mcdonald's you know
yeah
um let's quickly talk about the real
housewives of beverly hills episode two
harry hamlin's birthday um something i
did not see for this year was like rena
and erica like choosing violence and
choosing to be like villains because
that's what they are because i think
this is what it is and i kind of
understand this even though like they're
not i'm not on their team but like they
go about the show like in earnest i
think reyna's been on her best behavior
for a few years and like still the fans
don't like them and so it's like you
know what they're not going to like us
anyway let's at least say what we're
thinking
who we are and [ __ ] [ __ ] up and be
interesting and have a laugh about it
because like erica has gone off the
rails yeah she is a no filter none so i
thought the conversation about the elton
john party was really interesting
because
so like lisa really should have just
dropped it like really really should
have just dropped it um and just
accepted the apology when sutton
apologized but then she had to dig
deeper and of course sutton bought the
receipts in no world do i think that she
cancelled and that's why i was like
diana like shut up like i want to see
the receipt like yeah are you saying
okay sure it's tacky whatever but like
also since when diana just came in since
when we all have to listen to her that
she just because diana thinks it's tacky
even though like yeah if diana would be
like okay i'm yeah it's not that tacky
you know what was tacky that party in
the middle of the cafeteria like
literally it was not even like an
elegant far right there was nobody else
around it was just the women actually i
would beg to differ is that tacky at all
no it's the time and place and also it's
like if
rina is going to throw this allegation
out then suddenly to be able to it's
only fair just like sutton threw the
allegation out that reyna didn't thank
her and brenna has to defend herself
unfortunately this is something that now
needs a little bit more back and forth
yeah and receipts would be helpful so
diana please like pipe down because yeah
shut up we just need to get to the
bottom of this so we can move on because
it's actually not that interesting no
and i don't want it to linger so if
receipts can be shown and proven we can
put this thing to bed that would be
great yes i was actually really happy
that garcelle like insisted
sutton show the the receipt because
right sutton was like something's like
not she can't really go tit-for-tat with
people like she she's not as combative
as others no and like she like goes four
steps in three out like yeah
almost there but then kind of shies away
because she's not interested in beef and
so garcelle had her back which i really
liked and honestly i think that whole
scenario made lisa look terrible um and
then it was like sutton just couldn't
catch a break sutton versus erica
erica's just like she she is the villain
like it's so crazy that the journey
she's went on in the last two years
because i never thought there was a time
where like i wouldn't literally agree
with every breath that she breathed
and now it's like
she's so nasty yeah like really mean
really mean and she doesn't care anymore
and it's weird and uncomfortable to
watch i imagine it's weird to be around
like just two people telling each other
to shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] off
and
in different franchises are different
and i feel like in new york they speak
to each other that way all the time but
like when they were sitting there and i
think it was kyle who's like you guys
don't talk like that it's like they try
to stay above
certain things but erica's just going
there no and her tagline is really true
like there's nothing more dangerous than
someone who has nothing to lose and
that's literally erica like it's over
yeah so she's crawling her way out she's
taking everyone down with her yeah um
the other thing i thought was
interesting was diana so i we i didn't
really feel like they did an amazing job
of telling us like who she really was
like
what's her backstory and i did think the
i mean so she
she i forget the country that she was
from because sarajevo i've never heard
of it before oh sarajevo she moved to
london as like a refugee had literally
like not a pot to piss in for 10 years
she was like it was the most
excruciating time of my life cleaning
toilets like anything just to get by and
then she met this man and i actually
went online to research her because i
really wanted to know more about like
who he was and like what their vibe was
so he's not just some ordinary like
banker he's the president of barclays
like the biggest bank in the world
and
he's worth 500 million they did not have
a prenup
and i read this article in 2011 that
they like weren't together but they
didn't get officially divorced obviously
because it's like complicated
financially and they like he's like she
can have anything she wants but he also
wrote the article and was like if she
wants to get divorced like i will
happily fork over 250 million dollars
it's hers i couldn't have achieved what
i achieved with without her it was like
really sweet um
and i do believe they are now officially
divorced because that article was from
11 years ago and she's engaged right
which you can be engaged and still be
married to someone else it's a little
weird yeah for sure um
so i thought her backstory was
fascinating and she and i read an
article that said she's now the
housewife with the highest net worth
wow yeah that's exciting i know and you
could see it like her home was like this
sick house and she was like listing all
of her homes and they showed her house
in hidden hills which is not the house
she was in filming that one was i think
somewhere else um and she has london
she's all she's like i'm not bragging
i'm just telling you she's like five or
six houses and they're like sick yeah
and she said she like rotates like i
think she sells houses and gets houses
in new places she is that girl i feel
like it's rare that someone comes into
as a new housewife and doesn't have to
like work their way up through the group
like everybody just automatically
respects crystal knew her already lisa
knew her and people have probably heard
of her right like erica said she had
heard of her so
it's not like she just like win over all
the girls but sometimes it's an
interesting place to come in also
because like you you don't know how
things work around here but i'm just
very here for her it's also very
interesting that she just had a baby so
yeah like at 46. and she was like coming
in talking about she's having a hard
time losing the weight and i'm like okay
you are my girl no she's
first of all i did not know that that
man walking next to her was her fiance i
just thought he was like her friend i
was like shook yeah um
what i think is most interesting also is
especially in beverly hills she's
similar to sutton in the sense like it's
all her own money which is cool i mean
it's money like she's not married to she
was married to the money but now it's
hers yeah so it's like she can do
whatever the [ __ ] she wants yeah and
that's cool yeah i like her a lot me too
i think she was a good cast even though
i don't think they needed someone new
and it does feel like a lot of women i
feel like some people are gonna get left
behind even last season i felt like
dorit was getting like majorly left out
of the plot um i do think that's gonna
mean like some people become irrelevant
um things change things change yeah um
but diana's is super interesting yeah
yeah i didn't get a chance to finish the
episode um it's just weird because like
i'm really finding myself like on the
side of garcelle sutton and crystal yeah
because they're just like extremely
rational
people um and that's tough because like
watching the show for so long like you
feel so invested in like kyle and dread
but like and kyle's doing her best to
like straddle kyle and reed are kind of
neutral right now i think a lot of
people are gravitating towards garcelle
sutton and crystal sutton i'm like 50 50
on half the time i'm like yes half the
time i'm like no predictable yeah and
she's like being so weird in her
confessionals like just giving weird
energy she's getting [ __ ] with dory
she's wrong weird
i wish they let her finish speaking in
the car when she was like trying to
explain that she went over to kyle's and
i'm an empath and they didn't finish
what she was saying yeah what was she
gonna i don't know maybe she could say
like it took me a few days to like
really get that's what i thought she was
getting at and i regret like i don't
know yeah
so um
it will make for an interesting season
because i think that sutton garcelle and
crystal like definitely feel this like
resentment towards the fact that this
group really hasn't been that open yeah
but also they're wanting to distance
themselves from erica what was that l.a
times article that they did like being
like we could be a comp like we could be
i thought the la times article they were
referring to was like the og one from
last season erica said that l.a times
article really bothered me and they put
up a picture of an alley times article
called you know we could be
accomplished or indicted or whatever or
something maybe they were supposed to
get late it's a picture of the three of
them and it was like they sat down for
an interview and like had a photo shoot
and i think that's a little weird
sutton's track
you know i wish they dived into that
more
oh yeah on october 2021 real housewives
of oh we could be implicated however
scandal consumed the real housewives of
beverly hills and they're sitting at the
bar
sutton garcelle and crystal
it's at sutton strax bel air home
and they did
they did now that's not a bigger story
line is surprising and if i were erica
that would bother me the most and you
know what that's a little messed up
because it's like last season you know
crystal didn't want to hold erika
accountable yeah and and
i think that's where you're supposed to
do it on the show ask the questions you
know
they have defense have the victims in in
mind but you don't need to go and talk
to the press in their minds i think they
were doing an episode i think they
thought they were doing an interview
about being the three new girls listen
to these first couple questions okay
what has surprised you most about being
on the real housewives of beverly hills
knowing what you get with this franchise
what interested you in joining in the
first place and then they each answer
yeah um did denise richards or lisa warn
you uh about what to expect
the way race has been dealt with that's
uh talking to crystal and garcelle um
and then they probably asked one
question about eric and i made it the
headline
yeah wait some fans were frustrated that
you had to show your pain for the women
show empathy towards you literally when
do they get to erica
oh they're talking about the moment
where crystal challenge sutton on not
seeing color it literally has nothing to
do with erica
talking about sutton versus crystal
serious okay so ten questions later
things took a turn in the season once we
reached election day and erica's divorce
filing set off a series of questions
it's one thing to watch it as a viewer
and know a little bit about what to
expect but living in it must have been a
whirlwind so it's not like they sat down
to talk about erica but obviously that
is a click bait
that's crazy yeah
okay no wonder why no and then it was
one question yeah now it's like talking
about the dynamics of uh marriage and
wealth
and they literally like the headline
and it looks like they did a sit-down
interview about erica and you know and
by the way they probably once that came
out should have spoken to erica but
erica was so nasty to them why would
they give her any courtesy yeah so it's
not like they sat down but that is what
they made the article makes it seem like
but i don't think that they did got it
thank you for going through that because
you know another
muckraking moment
another another muckraking moment
um
so that's our show that's our show and
i'm so grateful for it oh my god that's
so sweet i'm grateful for you i'm
grateful for you and i'm grateful for
brass and thrashing oh and i'm grateful
for everyone who we got like over a
thousand youtube subscribers yesterday
let's keep the energy up you guys we
want our plaques okay
youtube.com sasha morning toast please
subscribe thank you guys so much for
listening have an amazing day thank you
so much for listening to morning chess
monday morning show where we deal with
the fastest stories that you need to
know every monday through friday new
youtube watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up or spells a little
background center where pogba has me
found some spotify i just need your
public radio everybody guys watch all
the places so we're going to listen bye
that's fine
i hope you guys have an incredible in
crowd
update okay and we'll see you guys
tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
bye y'all
bye
you